[music]
[music] [music] [music
] [music
] [
music]
[music]
Why aren't you answering the phone
?  The food won't be ready in time I
think it's good to take out, but
then you can't feel the sincerity anyway Anyway, please stop the
customers
Here, cut the
potatoes into chunks like this, and cut the tomatoes crosswise and then peel them with hot water.
I'll
do it all for you, so don't worry about it, it's
easy, right? I'm sure you'll be able to do it.  It's
not here, it's
over there [Music] Is it
here
?  It's
already sold out.
How about some crab instead?
I'm
going now.  It's the
same everywhere these days
What is this strange smell
[music]
Today's smell is
Onterington
Looking into your dreams and those eyes Tomorrow is
[music]  Have you
lost all of your documents? I have a
backup for
now,
so are you
worried
?
[Music]
Then let's eat together because it's a big deal
[Music] If you
look into those eyes of your dream, tomorrow will
be the fault [Music] Let's make it a miracle
Real strong Waifu, you
're our new boss From today  We are reindeer
[music]
No more no no no no